today we're going to be talking about
how to make Android apps beautiful and
we're going to start off by looking at
an app that hasn't had much love this is
actually the first in a multi-part
series of devbytes and today's episode
is going to focus on modernizing just
very doing some very basic modernization
techniques with your app so let's switch
to the phone and let's look at our our
app now the first thing I want to
actually point out is the app icon the
app icon is the identity of your app is
the identity of your app not only on the
user's device but also on the Play Store
so making this this piece of identity
standout and look polished is really
important this app does not qualify of
having done a good job so we've now
launched the app and you'll see it's a
very basic and a common pattern that we
normally see it's a ListView we have
some thumbnails on the left hand side
and some some text on the right and
straightaway we see that this app is
actually an old-style app it uses a
title bar at the top it has a legacy
menu button at the bottom which
shouldn't be there on a device with
virtual navigation buttons the images
are all inconsistently sized from from
each list item to list item and when we
go to the details we again we've got a
bad title bar but all the text is is
jutted up all the way to the edges so
let's look at what we do to fix this as
a first step what we're going to do
before we switch to code let's have a
look at what what the target is going to
be this is our first stage that we're
going to get to which is an action bar
we've got action items we've we've got
an overflow menu as well and we're doing
some notifications so getting back to
that let's now look at what we started
with let's look at some code and what we
have here is actually the manifest file
we've got a minimum SDK version set to
ten which is great we're targeting all
users from Gingerbread and up but our
target SDK version is also set to API
level 10 this should always be set to
the most recent version of the the
Android SDK which in this case is API 17
so the first change we'll make is to
make that 17 this will automatically get
rid of the menu button on devices that
have virtual navigation buttons the
other thing we want to do is actually
change the style we're using the fiend
Lite style so what we're going to do
instead is use our own style that is
also backwards compatible so our
manifest file is actually going to
change into something like this where
we've got API 17 here and we've got our
an app theme the way we're going to
define this app theme is by having a
Styles dot XML in our values directory
which just extends themed Lite this is
our base theme what we're then going to
do is we're going to have a Styles or
XML for v11 API 11 to 13 we'll get a
theme holo light and API 14 and upwards
we'll get the holo light with a dark
action bar so once we've done this we're
going to get a nice styled action bar
there I'm going to get rid of the menu
button but what we might also want to do
is brand our action bar to be more
consistent with the stylings of our
organization or service that we provide
switching to the slides now what we
actually want to do is take our action
by the way it is now and make it orange
basically and change the icon as well
again to be consistent without with our
brand the way we're actually going to do
that is use this third-party tool called
the Android action bar style generator
developed by Jeff gilt from the Android
developer community great utility where
you can go and specify various
attributes about how you want your
action bar to be presented and then what
it does is provides you with the zip
file that you can just extract over your
project and you're done
so that
subpart 1 I just want to show you how
far we've gotten in this checkpoint
we've gotten from something that
obviously looked old to something that
looks a lot more modern now